hello and welcome to this video playing
ring soon super clean from Germany yeah
good try that haven't done that for for
ages the color opening it's fairly
healthy it's basically i'm semi sloth
reverse in this way and tell me flowers
extremely well respected so let's see
what we phone is doing this is fairly
comfortable white I think hmm really
that works we should take h7 ok ok ok
here we go here we go here we go here we
go mmm so all kinds of things we G Force
one thing can also check here f5 and
then Queen g3 ok
it comes to the same thing okay let's
see if you find some defense IAM
it is extremely dangerous night x is six
maybe King to f6 but then I have 94 that
at least regained some material okay so
I have to ah that's an interesting way
actually no k 1596 look at 496 that's
important
not it it looks like a disaster like
hits no king move and 19 c 6 of such and
such an enormous threat so let's get win
the Queen Anne
like resigned yeah the kali opening
strikes fear yeah it's not not so easy
even though it has a harmless reputation
this is actually I think already not not
that good um I looked at this opening
some years ago and here it is best for
black to keep the tension so Queen c7 or
a 6 or h6 some of those moves are
interesting not sure about a six
actually maybe then I can also sacrifice
but taking is actually not a not so
great because um I get a very free
development now and it's not I mean he
has to lose time here that that is a
threat so h6 or Bishop is heaven one of
those move has to be played or you can
trade of course but this gets really
really annoying now that is a strong
pressure on black yeah and here i can
just sacrifice him okay going back is
completely disastrous and yeah it has to
go here here I wasn't entirely sure if
there is something else but there isn't
right I am I was building this but it's
the same it's the same story yeah i saw
this position and thought that that
should be over important is that after
king here I mean maybe something else
also works but this is simple and huge
yep i'm walking there for forcing him to
take and then hand Bishop g5 winning the
Queen yeah I mean he's got three minor
pieces but materialize I've also had one
and his pieces are coordinated so that
should be pretty good for want and maybe
I have something else in the engine also
wants to play 94 bit moves like that are
also quite interesting teen takes and he
escapes okay
can't with this movie in which is also
not that clear yeah 94 is the thing and
yet just lose even more material but i
think it was over you cannot allow we
should take h7 ok guys thanks for
watching